The answer is no. It repeats values too
infrequently. This may seem a little surprising.
If it was random, well the probability of two
consecutive values being equal should be to
the negative 128, a very low probability, but
not zero. If this is an encryption cipher, well
it satisfies the property of invertibility. So
any value that’s different here encrypts to a
different value. So that would mean that for
our actual pseudo random number generator, this
probability is actually equal to zero. And that’s
different from what it would be in a real random
sequence. This probability is low enough that we
still wouldn’t expect a repetition for a long
time, but we would expect to have one within
the first two to the 70 outputs. And we
will talk soon about the birthday paradox
to see why we would expect one this soon.
Still a pretty big number, but it would be enough
to distinguish this from pure randomness. So to
fix that, there is a couple of things we could do.
One is to occasionally change the key and after
some number of outputs we can take one output,
instead of using it as an output we use it as the
new key. So even if we don’t have any more
randomness, we will still change the key; that
will affect this probability, it will no
longer be zero, we will start seeing values
that have some probability of repeating what
we saw with the previous key. So we’ll
get a new key every few million outputs.
The other concern is whether this pool of
randomness is good enough? On Unix machines
there is a pool of randomness stored in
/dev/random and it is collecting events that
are believed to be random and out of the
control of the attacker. These could be user
actions like key presses; these could be
things that you collect over the network.
There is some risk that these could be compromised,
that some of them could be controlled or at
least predictable to the attacker. So we want
to have multiple pools of randomness and
combine them in a way that makes it very
difficult for an attacker to control this seed.
And this is essentially what the Fortuna
Pseudo Random Number Generator does
and that’s one of the more popular widely
used ones. It does use this routine to avoid
this apparently non-random property and it uses
multiple pools of randomness selected in a way
that makes it very hard for an attacker to control
what the seed is, even if the attacker can
control one or a few of the pools of randomness.